pick a card any card actually just pick
up all of them and take a look this
standard 52-card deck has been used for
centuries everyday thousands just like
it are shuffled in casinos all over the
world the order rearranged each time and
yet every time you pick up a well
shuffled deck like this one you are
almost certainly holding an arrangement
of cards that has never before existed
in all of history how can this be the
answer lies in how many different
arrangements of 52 cards or any objects
are possible now fifty-two may not seem
like such a high number but let's start
with an even smaller one say we have
four people trying to sit in four
numbered chairs how many ways can they
be seated
to start off any of the four people can
sit in the first chair once this choice
is made only three people remain
standing after the second person sits
down only two people are left as
candidates for the third chair and after
the third person is sat down the last
person standing has no choice but to sit
in the fourth chair if we manually write
out all the possible arrangements or
permutations it turns out that there are
24 ways that four people can be seated
into four chairs but when dealing with
larger numbers this can take quite a
while so let's see if there's a quicker
way going from the beginning again you
can see that each of the four initial
choices for the first chair leads to
three more possible choices for the
second chair and each of those choices
leads to two more for the third chair so
instead of counting each final scenario
individually we can multiply the number
of choices for each chair four times
three times two times one to achieve the
same result of 24 and interesting
pattern emerges we start with the number
of objects we were arranging for in this
case and multiply it by consecutively
smaller integers until we reach one this
is an exciting discovery so exciting
that mathematicians have chosen to
symbolize this kind of calculation known
as a factorial with an exclamation mark
as a general rule the factorial of any
positive integer is calculated as the
product of that same integer
and all smaller integers down to one in
our simple example the number of ways
for people can be arranged into chairs
is written as 4 factorial which equals
24 so let's go back to our deck just as
there were 4 factorial ways of arranging
for people there are 52 factorial ways
of arranging 52 cards fortunately we
don't have to calculate this by hand
just enter the function into a
calculator and it will show you that the
number of possible Arrangements is 8
point 0 7 times 10 to the 67th power or
roughly 8 followed by 67 zeroes just how
big is this number well if a new
permutation of 52 cards were written out
every second
starting 13.8 billion years ago when the
Big Bang is thought to have occurred the
writing would still be continuing today
and for millions of years to come in
fact there are more possible ways to
arrange this simple deck of cards then
there are atoms on earth so the next
time it's your turn to shuffle take a
moment to remember that you're holding
something that may have never before
existed and may never exist again
you